you met with Letterman and you had a 90
minute private meeting with him
I asked if before Dave went off the air
I wanted to go over there and really say
thanks for the 30 years he was on the
air and I mean I started college in 82
with the same year he started in late
night late over at NBC and Joe was
everything I asked him questions about
like the day-to-day is there anything
after 22 years you would have changed
about the space because you know like
nobody knows yeah man he goes I would
like to have tried the desk into the
side
he never said like I regret because I'd
like to have tried it on the other side
and so I said well I'll try it on the
other side have you spoken to him since
no listen he was generous I had an hour
and a half with him on a show night and
he had the show the next day he could
have been more gracious have you did you
ask him to be your first guest I bet you
did I'm not going to reveal anything
more about the conversation I had with
him and I would love to have Dave on the
show someday yeah that would be nice
they would be lovely